si hoy la comunidad internacional ha
hablado la asamblea general de la ONU
con una amplia mayoría aprobado una
resolución que pide a los países que no
reconozcan la anexión de esos
territorios ucranianos que Rusia se ha
hecho a raíz de un referéndum legal y le
pide también a Moscú que frene esa
anexión ilegal como digo ha sido apoyada
por una amplia mayoría de los miembros
143 miembros a favor de los 193 ha
habido 35 atenciones en las que entre
las que se encuentra ese socio
estratégico de Rusia que es China y
también ha habido cinco votos en contra
Rusia Siria Nicaragua Corea del Norte y
Bielorrusia antes de la votación Rusia
había pedido que se hiciera a Puerta
cerrada en secreto pero el resto de
miembros no lo han aceptado recordemos
que esta resolución viene ya del Consejo
de Seguridad de Naciones Unidas allí
Rusia vetó la resolución y por eso no
salió adelante pero aquí en la asamblea
general uno de los miembros tiene
derecho abeto de increíble la ha
catalogado el representante de Ucrania
por su parte la embajadora de Estados
Unidos linda Thomas Greenfield ha dicho
que esto demuestra que Rusia no puede
intimidar al mundo y antes de la
votación se ha dirigido a los Estados
miembros les ha dicho hoy es Rusia la
que invade Ucrania pero mañana podría
ser su país el que es invadido Y cómo le
gustaría que esta asamblea reaccionara
el representante de Rusia antes de la
votación también ha dicho que está
resolución esta politizada que además es
abiertamente provocativa y que frena
todos los intentos de solucionar este
conflicto por la vía diplomática